-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
let's get to the news.
Everyone is talking about
the Supreme Court
after they made
some pretty major decisions
over the last few days.
And let me just
sum it up for you.
They basically said,
whether it's a gun or a baby,
you're carrying something.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
On Friday, the Supreme Court
voted to overturn Roe v. Wade.
I don't have to tell you
that plenty of people
are furious with
the Supreme Court right now.
And in an attempt
to tamp down the anger,
the Supreme Court
released this message.
Watch this.
-We here at the Supreme Court
recognize that millions
of Americans are angry
over our recent actions.
But we really want to hear
what you have to say.
So, call us at 1-800 --
[ Mumbling ] -- 9,
or e-mail us at...
[ Speaking quickly ]
And you can always write to us
at the address on the screen.
The United States Supreme Court.
Because your opinion matters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You can just write them.
You can just find the address.
In response to the ruling,
President Biden said the Court
is literally taking America
back 150 years.
And if there's anyone who knows
what things were like back then,
it would be President Biden.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I saw that House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi
responded to the Court's
decision by reading a poem.
[ Laughter ]
Even Democrats were like,
"Look, if this poem
doesn't start off with
'Clarence Thomas'
and end with 'Nantucket,'
we don't want to hear
this poem."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, after the decision,
Clarence Thomas
went even further and brought up
banning contraception.
[ Audience groans ]
It's all part of his plan --
Operation: Get My Wife
Out of the News."
[ Laughter ]
That's right. A new poll
conducted this weekend.
A majority of Americans said
that they don't agree with
the Supreme Court's ruling.
In fact, 59% of Americans said
that they disapprove
of the ruling.
And that's not all.
52% of Americans said
that it's a step backward
for America.
While 48% said,
"Circle back next week.
I'm still mad about
the January 6th hearings
and how everyone just kind of
decided the pandemic was over."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Is it over?
33% said they don't really
see how politics affect them,
then paid 100 bucks
to fill their gas tank.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, 68% said,
"I'm literally too angry
to answer poll questions
right now."
[ Cheers and applause ]
So just hush.
Switching gears, this weekend,
President Biden left for Germany
to meet with other world leaders
at this year's G7 summit.
And, as always, the leaders
took a family photo together.
Here they are.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Looks like "The Bachelorette:
Senior Edition."
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
Over the weekend,
Rudy Giuliani claimed
that he got slapped
by a supermarket employee
and even went on to say,
it felt like
somebody shot him.
[ Laughter ]
That sounds pretty scary.
This is real.
We have
the surveillance footage.
This is real.
Let's take a look.
-There's Rudy.
Oh.
That was it.
[ Laughter ]
That was it?
He thinks that was a slap?
Clearly, Rudy didn't see
this year's Oscars.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
It makes sense
that he freaked out.
It's been 20 years since Rudy
got a pat on the back.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news.
This weekend,
the new movie, "Elvis,"
narrowly edged out
"Top Gun: Maverick"
for number 1 at the box office.
And apparently, it's so popular
that it already inspired
this new promo.
Watch this.
-Elvis" is officially
the number-one movie
at the box office.
And if you loved being
transported back to 1955,
then you'll love
"The Supreme Court."
Now playing in 29 states.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Interesting promo
for the movie.
Hey, guys, I saw
a new survey that said
the perfect temperature
for air-conditioning
during the summer is 64 degrees.
That seems cold.
64 degrees is perfect
if you're training Rocky
inside a meat locker.
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a perfect
temperature if you want to see
your dad's nipples
poking through his T-shirt.
-Oy!
[ Laughter and groans ]
Oh!
Ay!
-Hey, guys, I heard about
a family in Idaho
who came home
to a roofless house
after a roofing company
got the wrong address.
[ Laughter ]
The company was like,
"Uh, good news --
you got more outdoor space."
[ Laughter ]
I like how the neighbor
watched and was like,
"What a coincidence.
We're both having
our roofs replaced."
[ Laughter ]
And this went viral.
A news station in Los Angeles
wanted to have some fun
and surprise
one of their reporters
for her birthday,
but things didn't go as planned.
Here, take a look at this.
-Happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
[ Laughter ]
It's a floating cake.
-Wait. What --
-Ooh!
You have to zip up your face,
though.
Zip her up really quick.
We gotta see this.
Watch your hair.
There we go.
There we -- there --
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
[ Sad tuba ]
[ Rim shot ]
-Hey!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yep, they broke the zipper
and every ratings record
they ever had.
[ Laughter ]
Viewers were like, "Hey,
if that's the 8:00 a.m. news,
we can't wait
for the 11:00 p.m. news.
Oh, my goodness."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
it's the first time anyone
has ever seen
a literal news flash.
There you have it, everybody.
[ Laughter and applause ]